[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je suis pas certifié sur Tik
Tok ouh là moi je suis sortie
de ce soir full Fendi et petite montre
Chopard
tiens pas évidemment qui m'ont prêté
juste derrière moi il y a bécane et je
peux vous dire que bécane elle me
laissera pas repartir avec la montre au
poignet
ouais Vincent là par rapport aux travaux
là tu vois bon alors on a les travaux tu
vois là tu en penses quoi parce que je
voudrais juste savoir ici ce que tu
penses par rapport à ce volet là que
qu'est-ce que tu en penses pourtant
j'ai mis le mur trop près alors tu as
mis le mur un peu à la maison
ah alors bon je vais aller voir si c'est
le
ciao Milano get ready pour la Milan
Fashion Week
pour le défilé
look noir
on a un body noir air totalement Blanco
avec un truc par dessus quand même
c'est élégant ah franchement j'aime bien
bon on va un petit peu mieux une paire
de ballerines
[Musique]